Salut. Aujourd'hui je vous fais cette vidéo
depuis ma chambre d'hôtel.
Parce que je suis en tournée
à Narbone !
Juste avant de commencer cette vidéo,
pour info : j'ai beaucoup de chance,
grâce à vous,
je suis complet de plus en plus
en avance.
Donc, si jamais vous voulez
venir me voir à Montauban,
à Bordeaux, à Strasbourg,
à Sénas, à Mulhouse,
et dans d'autres villes,
vous pouvez cliquer sur le lien
qui est dans la description.
Petite info, si vous êtes de Bretagne,
de Pays de la Loire ou de Vendée...
Rajoutez moi sur les réseaux sociaux,
j'ai peut-être un truc à vous dire
en avril...
Aujourd'hui, je voulais essayer
quelque chose sur vous;
quelque chose que j'ai en tête
depuis un moment.
En interaction !
L'idée c'est de vous surprendre.
Peut-être.
C'est parti !
[Musique Générique]
Il va y avoir un mélange entre,
le rationel, la voyance, le mentalisme.
Une sorte de triptyque,
comme ça...
[Musique de X-Files]
Faut pas faire ce geste là, je crois...
Écrivez sur un bout de papier,
ou visualisez dans votre esprit
votre année de naissance
à l'envers !
De la fin vers le début.
Moi, je suis né en 1982,
ça fait 2891.
Si vous êtes né en 2003,
ça fait 3002.
Prenez le temps de visualiser,
pour ne pas vous tromper,
votre année de naissance
à l'envers.
Je vais maintenant vous demander
une petite soustraction très simple.
Vous pouvez la faire avec
une calculatrice
ou sur le papier.
Mais ne vous trompez pas.
Vous allez soustraire,
de votre année de naissance,
votre année de naissance à l'envers.
Ou !
C'est un choix, c'est votre liberté,
votre année de naissance à l'envers,
moins votre année de naissance.
C'est un petit peu dans l'ordre
que vous voulez...
Régulièrement, lors de cette vidéo,
je vais être obligé de dire des formules magiques.
Celle-ci est très très simple,
mais un peu dure à prononcer...
[la bande son passe à l'envers]
Ça fait bizarre ça un peu
dans les oreilles...
Passons à la phase de
numérologie :
Vous allez additionner
tous les chiffres ensemble.
Si vous avez un signe négatif,
vous l'oubliez.
Si votre résultat final c'est
-2891
Ça fait 2 et 8 : 10
et 9 : 19
et 1 : 20
Si votre résultat final c'est
3045,
vous faites : 3 + 4 -> 7
+5 -> 12
Pendant que vous faites cette petite
numérologie,
je vais en profiter pour dire la deuxième
formule magique.
Cette deuxième formule magique
c'est simple, c'est :
Euque ige ol
Vous avez compris ?
Euque ige ol.
En fait, il y a une version plus
longue de Euque ige ol,
[La bande son passe de nouveau à l'envers]
Vous avez un résultat final en tête,
il est issu de votre date de naissance
et de la numérologie.
Vous allez, dans le tableau suivant,
lire le mot qui est associé
à votre résultat à vous.
Voici le tableau avec toutes ses possibilités.
Vous lisez et vous retenez, évidemment,
le mot qui est associé
à votre résultat numérologique.
Pas la peine de faire pause
et je ne vais pas faire durer ce moment là,
vous devez déjà avoir votre mot
en tête maintenant.
Avant dernière formule magique :
[Bande son inversée]
Je crois que celui-là
c'est le plus compliqué, hein ?
Et pour terminer,
je vais vous demander de
prendre la dernière lettre
de votre mot
et, de cette dernière lettre,
d'imaginer un mot
en rapport avec votre mot
de départ.
Je m'explique un peu
plus clairement.
Un exemple très concret :
Si votre mot c'est Mer.
Je sais qu'il n'existait pas
dans le tableau celui-là.
Donc, si votre mot c'est Mer,
M, E, R
la dernière lettre c'est le R,
et un mot qui commencerait par cette
lettre en rapport avec le mot Mer,
ça pourrait être Radeau,
ça pourrait être Requin...
Je vous laisse donc quelques
secondes pour prendre
la dernière lettre de votre mot
et d'imaginer un mot en relation
avec votre mot de départ.
Qui commence par cette lettre.
Et vous me dites, dans les commentaires,
quand vous êtes prêts, pour que je continue...
Non, par contre, vous pouvez me dire,
dans les commentaires,
quel mot vous avez actuellement
en tête.
Ça ne changera rien, puisque
la vidéo est déjà faite.
Dès que vous avez votre mot,
vous l'écrivez.
Tout de suite.
J'imagine que ce doit être bon.
Alors, je ne vais pas révéler
le mot exactement,
mais je pense pouvoir révéler
le thème de votre mot.
Grâce à la dernière formule,
qui n'est pas si évidente non plus,
et qui se dit :
[Bande son inversée]
Je pense que le thème de votre
nouveau mot est en rapport avec euh...
les équations, avec l'esprit...
peut-être même avec
le monde des énigmes...
Je crois...
que c'est quelque chose comme ça...
Attends ! Je sais que ce n'est pas
très très bluffant.
Parce que c'est ça aussi,
mes dons de mentalisme me permettent
de dire que, de l'autre côté de l'écran,
vous êtes en train de vous dire :
"Oui... bon ça va... ce n'est pas non plus...
c'est ça, mais ce n'est pas exactement ça, quoi..."
Mais peut-être qu'il y avait une deuxième
chose de cachée dans cette vidéo...
Peut-être que, derrière les formules magiques,
il y avait une deuxième chose...
Ça vous dit qu'on se refasse tout ?
Mais à l'envers !
Pensez au mot que vous aviez
choisi au départ.
[Bande son inversée accellérée]
Imaginez que tout était prévu
depuis le début.
[Bande son inversée accellérée]
Ça voudrait dire que je connaissais
votre mot depuis le début
[Bande son inversée accellérée]
Au premier visionage vous allez choisir
le mot Lo Gi Que
Lo Gi Que
[Bande son inversée accellérée]
Si vous êtes encore là,
laissez un gros Like.
[Bande son inversée accellérée]
J'espère que cette idée vous aura plu,
si elle fait des émules,
je m'amuserai à écrire d'autres vidéos
comme ça, qui sont des vidéos
un petit peu de divertissement
logique, euh...
Ça m'a pris pas mal de temps
à créer ça, alors je vais me fixer une barre :
si on dépasse, je ne sais pas moi,
les 25.000 Likes par exemple,
je ressortirai une vidéo
dans le même style.
C'est une motivation pour moi aussi.
N'oubliez pas que, parfois, traînent des
surprises dans la description de la vidéo...
Merci d'avoir regardé ça,
vous pouvez vous abonner
comme d'habitude,
et rendez-vous très bientôt
Ciao ! ;)
[Musique générique de fin]